All My Life as a you know outside the
Lebanon of course I I've heard about uh
PTSD post-traumatic stress disorder
like people say oh people who witness
Wars have a post-traumatic stress
disorder said what the hell is talking
about eyewitness Wars and I'm certain
that I got better out of it from it
okay
well it turns out that there's something
called post-traumatic growth
okay whatever doesn't break of course it
can break you a lot of people get
traumatic stress disorder
but bad events make people grow
I mean up to a point of course about
events it can be you know something that
that kills you it doesn't make you grow
but so so there's something called
post-traumatic growth and psychologists
don't talk about it all they talk about
the disorder and the idea that nobody's
going to make any money selling you
uh uh you know post traumatic growth
they give you because they don't have to
treat you nature is treating you okay
well psychologists make money giving you
advice on your post-traumatic Disorder
so they like to put disorders and and
the whole attitude I have towards
medicine and everything is espresso and
anti-fragile is when I'm very sick I
don't go to the doctor I go to four
doctors
and if I'm mildly sick I go to no doctor
you see so so basically I overreact so
this is what people didn't get was
covered I react to pandemics monstrously
but I don't react to small little
deviations
so
and then of course the anti-fragile a
lot of people up regulate
on the stressor
that's supposed traumatic growth in
other words if you need stressors you
must get your stressors
so you know they're going to be wind
there's an expression in uh in the
states when life gives you a lemon you
make lemonade
so so you try to make you know and and
of course the only way to make lemonade
is lemon and lemon and is that is in in
English or in slang means a mishap okay
so when you have a mishap I don't know
how it translates into Ukrainian but the
idea is that you know there's going to
be a lot of wind so either you're going
to the basement and start crying and ask
for government money all right or
there's going to be a lot of win to say
oh I'm gonna make some money out of it
with wood bills so the the that's the
the main one and and if you look at the
history of civilization and countries
you see a parameter a little bit of
stressor has caused a lot of people to
do very well
I take the most successful country in
history Singapore they have no resources
so when you don't have resources you
tend to upregulate the Phoenicians had
no resources let's force them to you
know become merchants and one thing
leads to another so it gets you out of
the the
lithotical states and you look at Saudi
Arabia they have all the resources and
look what they've done with them
compared to Singapore
so
you realize that
in history it's good to be small for
reasons of scale as you see scale is
non-linear and it's also good to have no
resources
so the the in other words it's like
Venice you turn water into gold you
force so you upregulate
a little bit of a shock makes you better
that's the idea just like I lift weight
up regulate you see I get the stressor
uh pregnant and sometimes
companies a little bit of Chaos in
companies help them improve okay it
doesn't destroy them and help them
improve and sometimes some companies
even create their own uh chaos and and
let me tell you one thing the best
predictor of a bankruptcy of a company
is steady earnings
because it means they're not adapted to
to the environment
okay it's just like steady heart rate
and and for an individual if you have a
steady salary it destroys you okay
whereas I compare two brothers one had
uh it was on a salary the other one was
an entrepreneur and and you see them
they're making the same amount of money
but the other one was ironically a lot
more resistant
or they say fructose and Latin fluctuate
but if you fluctuate the more you
fluctuate without thinking the more
robust you are as compared to something
that's steady
and the best predictor actually of the
hedge fund that's going to collapse is
steady earnings it means they're taking
a lot of hidden risk
and of course the American economy
proved to be anti-fragile from this and
evolution basically is a mother of all
gainers of convexity because it benefits
from optionality and let me have this
adaptation mechanism works
um
if you uh simple if you uh
let's say you make mistakes and if you
have pathogenesis in other words you
don't have a sexual reproduction but you
reproduce yourself
if you produce yourself exactly as you
are with that variation
uh it's not gonna do you're not gonna do
very well the environment may change you
won't survive if you make mistakes and
you produce yourself and too many kids
once in a while it's sort of like a fax
machine that makes a mistakes okay A
Printing mistakes or produces a slightly
different organism so if you if it
doesn't work so what if it benefits it
gets better so
so the best way is to make small
mistakes but not too many
because if you your reproduce with too
much variation
then you won't retain the benefits of
previous adaptations so you need to have
a small written mistake
okay
and and of course when you have sexual
reproduction you still you have a lot of
kids you have variation between them you
don't want to be to be too far apart
traumatically but you don't want to be
too close okay you want them to be to
have a dispersion so some would survive
you're living difficult times I went
through that I tell you and believe me
think of post-traumatic growth that will
cheer you up
uh I mean our Warren Lebanon lasted my
child I mean a great part of my life and
you know it lasted uh more than a decade
and it was really completely mad because
it was several other neighborhoods and
uh and as you can see we're familiar to
that and uh
the bad guy you know you never know who
the bad guy is because
yeah things turned okay so uh but but so
so try to say okay this is gonna make me
tougher on this stuff around this it
helps a little of course and of course
you have to fight it upregulate things
um an army that haven't seen a war like
these Russians uh probably are not going
to do very well particularly they don't
have skin in the game fighting you know
a remote place from their place of
origin uh populations who live there
that cares about it anyway so but in
general I said how we can go from a
concept of fragility this is fragile to
non-linearity to everything non-linear
either loves or hate
volatility
within that within a range
and to why we need volatility within
life range
why we go to the gym it's the same idea
why we need stressors once in a while
all kind of stressors
and uh and you can generalized to many
many things
okay but but upregulating is is
something that people underestimate
but let me tell you one thing I remember
during the war in Lebanon what was what
struck me the most is that I was stuck
like you you're hiding now is you want
normency but then you read voraciously
see because at the time there was no
internet and I hope you keep the
internet and I'm sure you know musk will
help to make sure it still works but
there was there were basically no
internet my childhood but so we had
books okay and you create books and and
it made me you know a lot it made me
love literature love books just being
stuck and hiding and then underground
for months and months on end
I see that there is one question which
appears in different forms in chats uh
and on Facebook as well so people are
fascinated with the with this concept of
post-traumatic growth and even though
you have already you know explained it
people still ask you to repeat some key
ideas of it so what would be a
combination you know how to develop it
what what are the key points no no the
whole the whole point is to say that the
stressors you're gonna get uh is not
just a stressor that is uh
um good for you but there's something
needed
see the the something needed for your
growth
because I mean we humans never had a
peace in history we always had Treasures
subtle recently that we had this
post-war uh you know
quiet period
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]